[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
jeudi 25 janvier voici le programme de
ce soir la colère des agriculteurs
yelinois ne faiblit pas ce matin une
quinzaine de tracteurs ont mené une
opération et escargot entre mé et
rquencour nous étions à bord du convoi
pour recueillir leurs revendications un
olivier comme symbole de paix et de
sagesse aujourd'hui la communauté juive
s'est rassemblée à Versailles pour la
fête de tbichvat dans un contexte
particulier depuis les attaques du Hamas
en Israël les actes antisémites ont
augmenté de 1000 % en France le jeudi
comme d'habitude nous vous donnerons nos
idées de sortie pour le weekend au
programme de ce soir la nuit des
conservatoires des des concerts une
braderie et même un opéra nous partirons
également au Château de Rambouillet
jusqu'au 21 avril le monument vous
plonge dans les années 50 sans oublier
l'invité du 78 en 2ème partie d'émission
au mois de janvier les maires de
Saint-Quentin en Eveline viennent
présenter les projets de l'année 2024
dans leur commune ce soir Laurent Merker
le maire de Montini le Bretonneux sera
avec nous mais d'abord direction à la
nationale 12 la colère des agriculteurs
monte d'un cran une colère qui s'est
déclenché suite à la hausse de la
taxation sur le gasoil non routier au
1er janvier 2024 ce matin ils étaient
environ une quinzaine de tracteurs
amener une opération escargot entre mé
et rquancour notre journaliste Aurélie
lafeille était à bord du convoi pour
recueillir leur revendication là on va
démarrer d'ici 5 minutes euh je vais
passer en tête sur la sur le convoi tout
ralentir pour se faire entendre des
pouvoirs publics dès 6h ce matin plus
d'une quinzaine de tracteurs ont conduit
une OP option escargot sur la N12 et la
12 entre mé et le triangle de rquencour
après des actions menées hier dans le
secteur de Oudan la colère s'intensifie
à l'initiative de la Fédération
Départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricooles d'Île-de-France
les producteurs dénoncent la hausse des
taxes et des normes environnementales
jugées trop contraignantes les
revendications bon se résume à TR sur
trois angles il y a la dignité du métier
qu' l'on a pu de la part de nos élus il
y a l'aspect revenu qui est très
important pour nous parce que
aujourd'hui c'est le ner de la guerre
c'est ce qui nous fait vivre et puis
après il y a tout le côté normatif avec
la surtransposition des des normes
franco-fançaises avant on se met du
colza avec un produit qui traitait la
semence qui protégeit la plante contre
les insectes pendant 3 semaines après la
lev maintenant il est interdit ce
produit là il y a une semaine on a on a
passé le traitement en folière le
pulvérisation en folière avec un
insecticide qui marche plus ou moins
bien TR fois dans la semaine pour
protéger la culture pour arriver à ce
qu'elle lève suffisamment de pied de Lev
qu'avant on avait pas besoin de tout ça
Stéphane et séréaliier sur une propriété
d'une trentaine d'hectares dans les
ivelines et le Val d'Oise père de deux
enfants il ne les encourage pas à
reprendre ces terres une difficulté à
vivre de son métier pour lui une vraie
passion on n'est pas rémunéré à à ce
qu'on devrait on c'est un métier qui
crève la fin qu'on crève la fin quand
j'ai payé tous mes traitements mes
engrais si reste même pas allez 1000 €
pour faire l'année pour faire l'année
hein sur l'autoroute A12 trois voix sur
4 était neutralisé aux alentours de 8h
le temps de parcours entre Bois d'Arcy
et reconcours était d'1h15 au lieu de 6
minutes selon les données citadins le
Premier ministre Gabriel hatal fera des
annonces en faveur des agriculteurs ce
vendredi pour cette mobilisation à
l'échelle
nationale et en ATT attendant les
annonces du Premier ministre les
agriculteurs ont annoncé le blocus de
Paris demain entre 14h et minuit dans un
communiqué de presse la FDSEA
Île-de-France appelle au rassemblement
sur les grands axes autour de la
capitale cela devrait notamment
concerner la 13 la 10 et la 11 allez
c'est l'heure à présent de faire le
point sur le reste des informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir math alors on
continue de parler du ralbol des
agriculteurs hier certains ont pu
rencontrer une ministre dans les
ivelines oui il s'agit d'Aurore berger
la ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre les
discriminations était hier soir à Joire
Pontchartrin elle présentait ses vœux
aux habitants de la 10e circonscription
des Yvelines dont elle était la député
il y a encore quelques mois desvux au
côté du député actuel Philippe Emmanuel
et quelques AG culteurs ont donc profité
de l'opportunité pour faire remonter à
la ministre leur inquiétude plutôt dans
la soirée ils avaient pu également
échanger avec la sous-préfète de
Rambouillet Florence Gilbert on écoute
les propos recueillis par Nicolas
d'Andri on s'est un petit peu invité à
ses vœux en toute courtoisie pour
exprimer le le ralbol général qui monte
depuis des années puis là qui qui émerge
au niveau national là en ce mois de
janvier sera le bol il a un peu trois
trois thématiques
le problème de dignité du du manque de
reconnaissance qu'on a vis-à-vis de des
des consommateurs ou des politiques un
problème de revenu et un problème de de
surnorme de de surtransposition des des
règ la réglementation européenne au
niveau français tu es à leur disposition
pour les rencontrer comme j'ai toujours
été depuis 7 ans je pense qu'il faut pas
se tromper de combat on a un combat à
mener ensemble avec les agriculteurs
parce qu'encore une fois on a
l'alimentation la plus durable et la
plus saine au monde et c'est d'abord ça
qu'il faut rappeler donc qui est de
l'exigence évidemment je comprends on a
envie d'être de plus en plus exigeant
mais on est déjà encore une fois ceux
qui somes le plus donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi aussi rappeler ça direction
Versailles à présent où une fête juive
était célébrée aujourd'hui oui vous
l'avez dit mail de la fête de
toubichevat il s'agit du nouvel an des
arbres qui a lieu cette année le 25
janvier pour l'occasion un olivier a été
planté dans les jardins du domaine de
Madame ellisabeth à Versailles c'était
une première la plantation s'est faite
en présence de représentants de la
communauté juif dont le grand Rabin de
France Rahim corcia mais aussi de
plusieurs élus locaux l'initiative de
planter un arbre dans les ivelines pour
cette fête a été lancée par Samuel
Sandler l'ancien président de la
communauté juif de Versailles père et
grand-père on le rappelle de trois
victimes des attentats de Toulouse et
Montauban qui est décédé le 12 janvier
dernier on écoute ces interviews au
micro de Grégory canalé on a pour
tradition de planter un arbre c'est ce
qu'on vient de faire on a planté un
olivier c'est le signe d'un renouveau
c'est le signe de la vie on a repris une
initiative qui avait été menée par
Monsieur Samuel Sandler qui avait planté
en 2002 quand il était président de la
communauté juive de Versailles un arbre
pour tout Bichevat à l'arboretom du
chînet et il nous avait souffl en
novembre cette idée qu'il aurait aimé
revoir voir le jour et quand on lui a
annoncé que que nous allions replter
mais cette fois-ci à Versailles il en
était plus que ravi voilà et c'est
encore plus beau aujourd'hui de se dire
qu'on a planté qu'on a une énorme pensée
pour lui une fête qui veut véhiculer un
message positif dans un contexte
particulier celui de la recrudescence
des actes antisémites en France ils ont
augmenté de 1000 % depuis l'attaque du
Hamas en Israël le 7 octobre dernier
écoutter Ellie Corchia président du
conshistoire centrale Israélite de
France présent également aujourd'hui à
Versailles depuis le 7 octobre on s'est
rendu compte que nous avons eu une
augmentation de 1000% en l'espace de 3
mois des actes antisémites en France
comparé à l'année dernière et sur toute
l'année ça donne du coup un chiffre de
plus de 300 % d'augmentation ce qui est
ahurissant puisque nous avons eu une
déferlante d'acte antisémite dès le 7
octobre dès qu'il y a eu en Israël ces
pogromes terroristes qui ont été menés
contre la population civile et bien nous
avons vu et puis le festival de musique
de de Nova qui a été décimé par les
terroristes et bien nous avons vu des
actes antisémites dans les jours qui ont
suivi nous avons vu des des actes
antisémites qui qui ont qui ont déferlé
en France donc c'est aussi pour ça que
dans cette cérémonie on voulait montrer
un message positif et la grande majorité
de ces actes antisémites visent les
personnes il s'agit de menaces
d'insultte mais aussi de violence
physique on poursuit ces information du
jour Gabriel à Saint-Quentin en Yveline
oui l'agglomération tient ce soir sa
cérémonie de vœux au Vélodrome national
situé à Montini lebretonux et sur place
pour la rédaction de tv78 Grégory canalé
bonsoir grégoryi la cérémonie débute à
19h bonsoir Gabri 19h et on procède
actuellement au derniers préparatifs les
derniers échauffement puisquon on est
dans une sportive avant cette cérémonie
alors dans le discours on n pas pu
encore consulter dans les qu' allit dire
le président de l'agglomération de sa
iveline Jean-Michel Fourgous mais il y a
fort à parier qu'il sera question
deson attend avec ici du côté de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en ivine
puisque des épreuves vont se dérouler ê
sur le territoire ici même au Vélodrome
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste il y
aura aussi les épreuves de BMX juste à
côté sur la du Vélodrome national de 50
ans en neline les épreuves de VT sur la
colline d'élencour et bien sûr les
épreuves de golf au Golf National à
courour alors vous le savez aussi hein
dans ces cérémonies de vœux c'est la
tradition il y a des élus territoire
nationaux présents dans ceux qui ont
confirmé leur présence on n' pas la
liste établie mais on peut vous
confirmer déjà la ce soir du Sénat
Gérard Larcher qui sera donc au côté et
de 50 ans en Yveline pour cette
cérémonie de vœux qui débute ici à 19h
national merci beaucoup Grégory canalé
je crois que Lauren Merker sera aussi
également présent le maire de Montini le
Bretonneux il nous l'a dit à l'instant
on termine avec une information Gabriel
qui peut intéresser les jeunes en
orientation et qui doivent saisir en ce
moment leur vœux sur parcours sup
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yveline ouvre ses portes au public ce
samedi 27 janvier oui tout à fait
Mathilde la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques accueillera ses
futurs étudiants potentiels entre 14h et
18h des rencontres avec les professeurs
et les anciens élèves seront possibles
sur ce campus de guyancour en parallèle
des conférences seront animées pour
connaître les formations et les
différentes débouchées des métiers du
droit et de la science politique on
écoute Alain buit président de
l'université de Versailles 50 an en
Yveline on accueille tous les étudiants
on accueille des étudiants avec
desmensions très bien on accueille aussi
des étudiants avec des résultats un peu
plus modestes au bac et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que et c'est ce qui
fait la force de l'université c'est que
ça permet à tous ces étudiants de
révéler leurs talents et parfois on a
des extraordinaires euh expériences avec
des réussites
extraordinaires merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news allez c'est l'heure à présent de
passer à notre page
[Musique]
loisir et on ouvre cette page loisir
avec vos idées de sortie Gabriel pour ce
weekend on commence avec un concert qui
aura lieu demain soir à la lanterne de
rambouillé oui tout à fait Mathilde et
àaffiche l'artiste Arthur ha il
présentera notamment son dernier album
intitulé La Vie un album dans lequel on
retrouve la poésie de l'artiste mêlé à
l'énergie du rock et de la pop qui lui
sont caractéristiques pour assurer sa
première partie la chanteuse Lisa
Portelli à l'approche du spectacle nous
avons rencontré l'artiste regardez son
interview
[Musique]
express je suis chanteuse musicienne
avant tout enfin je me considère des
fois plus comme musicienne que comme
chanteuse mais je suis vraiment
chanteuse j'ai sorti cinq album à la
base je suis guitariste électrique et
mais maintenant mon ma musique est à
très électronique aussi euh j'ai été
attirée par par le fait de chanter à
travers des envies de poésie euh mais
rock la poésie elle est inhérente à mon
travail je pense que même la poésie
c'est un rapport au monde donc il se il
transpire dans la dans la façon de faire
la musique qui est très particulière
singulière et c'est ça qui me plaît donc
même ma façon de faire de la musique
électronique elle est elle est poétique
finalement parfois même un peu
expérimentale et j'assume complètement
mais il y a les mélodies sont très
importantes pour moi donc donc et c'est
très éteré parfois et et parfois très
très
[Musique]
brut
e j'atteint l'inge d'or l'innocence
retrouvée tremble en moi la douceur la
chaleur de l'été j'ai longtemps parcouru
les vallées
d'infortune tant de prières froides les
Tanis de mes
[Musique]
amertumes en première partie d'arthurche
étant donné que je suis en finalisation
de mon prochain album qui s'appelle
absence je vais jouer ces morceaux qui
sont pas encore sortis qui sortent le 8
octobre 2024 absence c'est c'est un
voyage j'ai raconté un voyage en
plusieurs étapes chaque chanson est
l'étape d'un voyage histoire c'est une
femme qui fait un voyage au fond des eos
et qui finit recraché par la mer tout
[Musique]
simplement
et pour assister au concert quelques
places sont encore disponibles sur le
site internet de la ville de Rambouillet
la musique à l'honneur ce weekend
Gabriel puisque ce sera également la
nuit des conservatoires oui l'événement
national fait son retour pour une 11e
édition cette année encore la
programmation est gratuite et ouverte à
tous l'objectif célébrer la richesse et
la diversité de nos conservatoires au
travers d'une soirée festive au
programme de la musique sous toutes ses
formes chorales orchestre ou encore
représentation théâtrale vous attendent
parmi les villes partenaires trois
villes à Saint-Quentin en iveline il
s'agit de morpas trappe et plaisir qui
vous donne rendez-vous dès 18h le
programme en intégralité est à découvrir
sur le site de vos communes direction
poissie à présent avec une exposition à
découvrir à la maison de fer oui je vous
propose de redécouvrir poissie à travers
la photographie jusqu'au 26 février le
photographe Maxime vistico expose à la
maison de fer de poissis au travers de
ces photos on découvre la cité
Saint-Louis sous un nouveau regard avec
charme et authenticité et la
particularité de cette exposition
Mathilde c'est que tous les clichés ont
été pris à l'argentique ce qui donne ce
côté rétro que vous voyez à l'image
c'est un peu devenu votre lieu culturel
préféré la maison Gabriel on poursuit
avec vos idées de loisirs à Versailles
un opéra baroque vous attend durant tout
le weekend oui vendredi samedi et
dimanche l'opéra royale de Versailles
accueille don quiichot chez la duchesse
d'après l'œuvre de favar et Boismortier
au fil d'une intrigue délirante où le
héros croise tour à tour monstre
enchanteur ou encore princesse ce balai
Comédy vous transportera au travers de
ses actes entre danse et cœur décalé et
audacieux un spectacle tout public à
découvrir en famille attention par
contre Mathilde il ne reste plus que
quelques places on termine avec un bon
plan une braderie gratuite ce samedi à
Guill en cours oui son nom gratiferia le
principe de cette braderie vous l'avez
dit vous pouvez prendre dont vous avez
besoin dans la limite de trois objets
par personne l'avantage c'est que vous
pouvez le faire complètement
gratuitement alors parmi les objets à
découvrir livre décoration ou encore
jouets ou petits électroménagers une
bonne initiative vous connaissez
toujours les bons plans gabrielou j'aime
bien les partager en plus donc merci
beaucoup Gabriel vous avez une autre
idée de sortie à nous proposer il y a
quelques jours vous vous êtes rendu au
château de rambouiller le monument
propose jusqu'au 21 avril une exposition
qui nous plonge dans l'intimité du
président Vincent Oriol à travers les
meubles et la décoration on retourne
dans les années 50 c'est assez bluffant
regarder on se dirige en fait vers
une des
chambres de cet étage
présidentiel une plongée dans le temps
et dans l'histoire du château de
Rambouillet après un an de travail de
reconstitution avec le Mobilier national
le site a retrouvé son style des années
50 Vincent auiol est alors président de
la République après la guerre il a une
ambition faire de rouiller une vitrine
des arts décoratif français la plus
grande spécificité c'est cette volonté
de redonner vie à l'ensemble des Arts
Décoratifs français à la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale vous êtes ici
dans un palais dans un château
présidentiel et le président Vincent
ryol a voulu mettre en avant la
décoration chose rare pour l'époque la
présidence va faire appel à de nombreux
décorateurs mais aussi des décoratrices
cette chambre donc a
été décoré par Suzanne guigichon nous
sommes dans ce qui est la chambre de
Paul Oriol qui était fils de Michel et
Vincent rol le président dans cette
chambre avec vue un mobilier
contemporain où le luxe à la française
est représenté toutes ces
caractéristiques vous les trouvez
également aussi bien pour les table de
chevet le lit avec ces immenses plages
donc de parchemin tout au long de la
visite une enfilade de pièces h style
unique et où le temps semble s'être
arrêté parmi elle l'appartement des
chefs d'État étrangers où de nombreuses
personnalités ont séjourné comme un
certain Nelson Mandela en
1996 aujourd'hui le palais n'est plus
présidentiel mais il continue de se
réinventer avec cette exposition
exceptionnelle l'objectif est de refaire
vivre l'histoire du lieu c'est vraiment
la période pour ambouillet qui a été la
plus fertile en matière de création en
matière d'art décoratif parce que
c'était un véritable chantier qui s'est
déroulé ici de même qu'à l'Élysée
d'ailleurs puisque les Orioles ont voulu
faire des résidences présidentielles les
vitrines des savoir-fair Français en
matière d'art décoratif donc c'est
vraiment les plus grands décorateurs on
dirait aujourd'hui designers qui ont
travaillé pour le couple Oriol et qui
ont déer des pièces magistrales pour
Rambouillet si certaines pièces seront
restituées à la fin de l'exposition le
château continue à écrire une nouvelle
page de son histoire avec le
réameublement d'autres pièces dans les
années à
venir et c'est bientôt l'heure de passer
à l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de demain et de ce
weekend demain matin le ciel sera gris
au-dessus des zvelines prévoyez
également quelques averses dans le
secteur de Houdan côté température il
fera toujours assez doux le matin avec
10°gr à rambouiller 11 à Versailles et
Houdan et 12 à Mantel jolie l'après-midi
le ciel devrait se dégager dans le
nord-ouest du département au niveau des
températures compté en moyenne 11° pour
les prévisions météo de ce weekend nous
devrions avoir du beau temps samedi le
ciel sera dégagé avec des températures
d'environ 2°gr le matin et 8°gr
l'après-midi dimanche météo France
annonce un ciel toujours aussi bleu et
il fera en moyenne 3°gr le matin et
11°gr l'après-midi c'est à présent de
passer à l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et l'invité du 78 ce soir c'est le
maire de Montini le Bretonneux Laurent
mercard bonsoir bonsoir bonne année 2024
ainsi qu'à tous les inimontins merci
très bonne année à vous également et à
l'équipe de tv78 merci beaucoup alors
lors de votre cérémonie des vœux de la
semaine dernière Laura Merker vous avez
comparer votre mandat un Ultra Trail
alors comment s'est passé la course pour
l'année 2023 quel qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de l'année écoulé alors c'est
une année qui a été véritablement
exceptionnelle à la fois par le contexte
puisque nous avons eu la crise
énergétique qui a impacté absolument
tout le monde et et les collectivités en
particulier et puis concernant la vie
plusieurs dossiers très importants ou
concrétisation très importantes ça a été
l'ouverture après une grosse phase de
réhabilitation du club le village avec
une offre modifiée transformée avec du
foutsall avec du padel en plus du tennis
du squash qui existait déjà précédemment
du badminton et puis un bâtiment
thermiquement transformé vraiment on est
sur quelque chose qui n'a plus rien à
voir avec le club le village que les
gens connaissaient nous avons eu aussi
la signature d'erbus sur l'année 2023
donc un moment extrêmement important
2027 qui arrivera en 2027 absolument sur
le territoire nous avons eu le départ de
la dernière étape du Tour de France qui
s'est faite le 14 juillet au Vélodrome
cet été donc ça c'était un moment assez
magique et et qui nous aide déjà un peu
à à imaginer ce que pourront être les
Jeux Olympiques l'été prochain nous
avons eu aussi sur la ville des travaux
sur tous nos équipements sportifs et je
pense particulièrement au stade de foot
à Coubertin le terrain de football qui a
été refait en synthétique la nouvelle
piste des de du matériel de street
workout installé là-bas
également nous avons eu aussi la
refondte de notre site internet nous
avons eu aussi notre journal qui a été
transformé Ann complète voilà voilà on a
beaucoup travaillé mais alors depuis le
début de ses entretiens avec les maires
de 50 ans nvine il a quand même des mots
qui reviennent inflation crise
énergétique on comprend qu'il y a un
contexte compliqué au niveau des
finances pour les collectivités est-ce
qu'à cause de ce contexte compliqué vous
allez devoir augmenter les impôts locaux
à Montini alors depuis plusieurs années
nous travaillons à essayer
d'optimiser tous nos services tous nos
modes de fonctionnement pour ne pas
justement
avoir à à augmenter le taux
d'imposition par exemple sur le la crise
énergétique nous avons réussi à faire
une diminution de consom tion de gaz sur
l'année de 13 % et ce chiffre de 13 % 13
euh cette année-là en 2023 et ben il
sonne doublement parce que c'est aussi
la 13e année où nous n'avons pas
augmenté le taux d'imposition sur
Montini et j'évoquais juste avant
l'arrivée d'erbus c'est vrai que nous
avons la chance d'avoir un tissu
d'entreprise extrêmement important sur
le territoire de Montini et c'est aussi
pour ça que nous nous battons à
l'échelle de Montini mais à l'échelle de
50 ans en yeline pour conforter
l'activité sur cette zone euh attractif
parce qu'il y a la gare parce qu'il y a
les sorties d'autoroute et euh c'est
vrai que c'est une richesse à la fois
pour le territoire de l'agglomération et
pour la ville de Montini qui nous permet
avec les économies que nous faisons pour
l'instant de ne pas avoir augmenté les
impôts alors avant de parler des grands
projets à venir pour l'année 2024 à
Montini je vais vous poser la question
Laurin Merker est-ce que le PSG va
construire un nouveau stade à Montini le
Bretonneux c'est une rumeur qui circule
alors plus qu'une rumeur puisque l'éipe
c'est sorti dans l'équipe c'est une
information qui est sortie dans l'équipe
non pas à la demande du PSG ni de la
ville ou de la communauté
d'agglomération ou de la région qui est
propriétaire du terrain donc c'est
plutôt une fuite en revanche
effectivement nous avons bien été
contactés les uns et les autres il y a
un peu plus d'un an à présent pour nous
annoncer que le club réfléchissait à une
autre solution que le Parc des Princes
et que dans ce contexte-là parmi les
solutions envisagées il y en avait une à
mon
Bretonneux nous
depuis le dossier est est resté en
suspens il y a des négociation entre la
Ville de Paris et le club je prends pour
l'instant cela comme
une une marque en tout cas d'intérêt et
la mise en valeur de des atouts que nous
pouvons avoir sur le territoire donc je
le prends très positivement pour cette
raison et donc ce stade serait il serait
sur le proximité de l'île de loisir
absolument c'est ça et et écoutez bien
nous verrons bien comment avancec les
discussions entre le paris-germain et la
ville de Paris nous de notre côté nous
sommes prêts à travailler avec eux si
nécessaire alors dans les grands projets
pour l'année 2024 Laura Merker la
transformation de l'hypercentre et
notamment des alentours de la gare avec
la démolition de ce qu'on appelle
l'anneau rouge qui devrait avoir lieu
cette année prochainement oui qui
devrait intervenir alors nous le ferons
après les Jeux Olympiques parce que ça
va faire énormément de de de ça va être
un chantier impressionnant important et
donc on imagine mal de le faire au
moment où les où les gens viendront voir
les épreuves donc on le fera juste après
ça va complètement transformer
effectivement la première vision que
l'on aura de la ville et du territoire
en sortant de la gare puisque jusqu'à
présent nous étions sur une place fermée
et demain et bien ce sera ouvert on
donnera sur l'avenue du centre on
donnera sur le parc qui est situé en
face et donc on aura une image plus
juste de ce qu'est le territoire
c'est-à-dire à la fois de l'activité
mais aussi du logement et aussi de la
nature et la nature au cœur de la ville
toujours dans les travaux qui sont
prévus dans le centre-ville des travaux
sur l'avenue du centre et sur la place
Pompidou qu'est-ce qui va changer tout
tout va changer puisque c'est une
conception un urbanisme qui date des
années 80 où la priorité était donnée à
la voiture donc demain c'est au
contraire c'est de redonner complètement
la place au piéton donc nous allons
réduire les voies nous allons créer des
pistes cyclab nous avons nous allons
agrandir Les Terrasses nous allons
agrandir les trottoirs de façon à ce que
les gens ne passe plus par là mais
puisse avoir l'envie d'y passer du temps
parce que l'endroit est plaisant parce
qu'il est vert aussi on va beaucoup
planter de de végétation et d'arbres
donc véritablement donner un visage
beaucoup plus chaleureux vert attractif
à cette partie de la ville qui est si
importante et les travaux vont commencer
après les Jeux Olympiques là aussi oui
oui oui absolument oui oui et donc autre
domaine qui vous tient à cœur à Montini
Laurent Merker c'est l'éducation en 2024
vous lancez les assises de l'éducation
qu'est-ce que c'est alors nous les avons
lancé même en en 2023 sur le le dernier
le dernier trimestre 2023 puisque nous
avons
fait alors l'objectif de tout cela
d'abord c'est d' de proposer demain une
nouvelle offre éducative dans nos
écoles puisque le monde change la
société évolue et parce que nous
disposons sur la ville de nombreux
moyens que ce soit au niveau sportif ou
culturel et scientifique pour pouvoir
apporter
d'autres éléments aux enfants que
l'enseignement traditionnel et donc nous
avons pour cela souhaité de mettre en
place une méthode originale c'est-à-dire
non pas de travailler nous ville sur le
sujet mais de faire travailler les
différents publics concernés donc on a
fait élaborer un questionnaire à
l'attention des différents publics que
sont les parents les enseignants les
enfants et les personnels qui
travaillent dans les écoles et ce sont
des personnes issues de chacun de ces
groupes qui ont constitué les
questionnaires qui ont été adressés à
chacun de ces groupes nous avons eu un
retour extrêmement positif puisque 100 %
dans toutes les catégories et pour celle
des parents 53 % des familles ont
répondu ce qui est énorme euh et suite à
cela nous avons fait le 11 janvier
dernier une soirée de réstitution
d'ailleurs en partenariat avec TV tv78
et la présence de Patrice carmous pour
montrer un petit peu tous les résultats
que nous avions obtenu et le travail que
nous allons faire sur 2024 c'est de
mettre en place cinq groupes de travail
sur des thématiques comme comment on
veut l'école de demain au niveau du
bâtiment comment on veut la cour d'école
comment on définit la journée de
l'enfant euh tout ce qui tourne a aussi
autour de la transition écologique c'est
combien de personnes au total qui
travaillent sur ce projet alors là par
exemple sur ces ateliers qui vont se
mettre en œuvre nous allons avoir trois
représentants de chacune des catégories
que j'ai évoqué euh qui donc 12
personnes qui travailleront sur chacun
de ces groupes et puis ensuite il y aura
des temps de restitution puisque tout ce
que nous faisons nous le restituons à la
population par exemple le questionnaire
que nous avions fait nous avons fait une
présentation le soir du 11 mais nous
avons mis en ligne absolument tout tous
les informations toutes les informations
toutes les réponses que nous avions
obtenu et on veut fonctionner comme ça
tout au long ce sont les les usagers qui
travaillent sur le sujet et nous
restituons à l'ensemble des habitants
tous les éléments de la de la
concertation donc les ateliers ont déjà
commencé ils vont être resc fin fin
janvier ser et ils vont durer jusqu'au
mois de juin donc il y aura un certain
nombre de d'ateliers qui vont se tenir
comme ça jusqu'à la jusqu'à avant l'été
de façon à pouvoir définir des pistes de
réflexion et de nous préparer à des
choix ensuite sur ce que nous pourrons
mettre en œuvre dans les prochaines
années dans les écoles pourquoi cette
volonté à montinier le bretonux de
travailler sur l'école de demain parce
que la politique de l'éducation et
l'accompagnement de la jeunesse pour une
ville est une des politiques essentiel
et que avec mes les élus de mon équipe
nous sommes absolument convaincus que
c'est un injeu fondamental la société
change énormément des tas de
problématiques se font jour aujourd'hui
auxquelles il faut savoir répondre et et
et encore une
fois on on sait aussi que on l'a évoqué
le soir du 11 un enfant on a tendance à
découper entre le moment du périscolaire
puis de l'école puis de la cantine du
soir et cetera or il est le même toute
la journée et donc devoir un petit peu
comment l'accompagner de manière
cohérente sur toute la journée et de
pouvoir lui apporter ce dont il a besoin
pour que demain il soit capable de
traiter l'information de manière
correcte par exemple et de ne pas tout
avaler tout ce qu'on lui donne qu'il
puisse aussi savoir se comporter par
rapport aux autres dans l'estime de soi
dans le harcèlement bénéficier aussi de
tous les apports en culture en sport en
science et bien d'autres domaines encore
qu'on où les langues que l'on pourrait
apporter en plus de l'enseignement
traditionnel ce sont tous ces sujets qui
nous paraissent nous vraiment importants
on va parler des Jeux Olympiques Laura
Merker 183 183 jours avant les Jeux
olympiques de Paris à Montini il va y
avoir plusieurs épreuves celle de BMX de
vélo sur piste et de vélo sur route
comment se pr par ce grand rendez-vous
mondial est-ce que tout est prêt alors
il se prépare de différentes façons
d'abord il y a la partie qui dépend du
Comité
olympique sur laquelle le travail se
fait en lien avec les services de la
préfecture et donc le Comité olympique
qui n'est pas forcément la partie la
plus simple parce que le comité
olympique a des manières de faire et
nous nous avons une connaissance du
territoire et donc il faut qu'on
confronte un petit peu tout ça mais je
suis sûr qu'on va y arriver et ensuite
il y a évidemment tout le travail que
l'on fait à l'échelle de la ville et à
l'échelle de Saint-Quentin sur ce qu'on
appelle l'héritage des jeux c'est-à-dire
quand évidemment il y a la nécessité
qu'il en reste quelque chose hein ce
sont des budgets quand même qui sont
assez importants donc nous ce que nous
avons mis en place depuis déjà plusieurs
années c'est un programme de bénévole
c'est un une sensibilisation des enfants
dans les écoles au savoir rouler à
bicyclette on a mis en place un module
avec notre vélo club de Montini qui nous
a permis de faire passer le département
des ivelines premier de France en en
apprentissage du savoir rouler auprès
des enfants donc cette démarche là
sensibilisation à différentes
disciplines sportive également hein et
nous allons poursuivre comme ça jusqu'à
jusqu'à cet été nous mettrons en place
aussi une semaine olympique à la fin du
mois de juin et puis il y a aussi avec
Saint-Quentin en yeline une très belle
idée de mettre en place une une fan zone
sur le l'île de loisirs cet été de façon
à ce que les gens puissent profiter
puisqu'on sait que très peu de gens
onuront finalement accès aux places dans
les équipements sportif du territoire
puisque c'est mondial et qu' AA des gens
qui viendront de partout mais de pouvoir
créer autour de de de des Jeux
Olympiques un événement festif quelque
chose d'attractif et qui puisse donner
envie aux gens de de participer et
d'être ensemble autour de de ces valeurs
alors enfin pour terminer cet entretien
Laura merc vous avez 30 secondes pour
votre carte blanche vous pouvez aborder
le sujet de votre choix ah ben écoutez
alors moi j'aurais j'aurais abordé les
assises de l'éducation
euh je dirais simplement sur l'année
2024 que le programme va être tout tout
aussi enthousiasment que sur l'année qui
vient de s'écouler puisque nous allons
ouvrir une nouvelle crèche sur le
quartier de la Sourderie nous allons
réhabiliter thermiquement une autre
crèche qui est la plus grosse de la
ville c'est la comptesse de Ségure qui
est sur le quartier CTIN on va également
ouvrir un city stade un nouveau city
stade sur le sud de la ville là aussi en
rapport avec le sport euh donc nous
allons avoir encore nous aurons
l'ouverture aussi de la Fondation Anne
De Gaulle et là c'est un sujet la
thématique du handicap qui nous tient à
cœur et j'espère vraiment qu'avec ce que
j'appelle ce 9e quartier de la ville de
Montini qui va s'ouvrir et bien nous
allons faire un bon encore plus
important dans le domaine de l'inclusion
sur la ville et ça voilà s'il y a un
sujet important et sur lequel je veux
finir c'est celui-là donc encore de
nombreux projet à Montini le
bretonnaisormément merci Laurent mercard
d'avoir accepté notre invitation encore
une bonne année 2024 à Montini merci et
c'est la fin de ce 78 merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur tv78 et excellent weekend
prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous